foreign
I mean we very much were raised to hide
your crazy and just go on just you know
we were supposed to be very stoic and
not tell anybody anything
[Music]
this is John with the Dr John deloney
show shall we talk about your mental and
emotional health
in your marriage and your dating
relationships and just trying to
navigate life figure it out in a world
that is gone mad
we talk about everything on the show
whatever you're struggling with whatever
you're going through my promise is I'll
tell you the truth and if I don't know
I'll tell you I don't know and if I need
to reach out to one of my friends across
the country who's an expert I'll do that
too but the goal here is to sit with you
and hear your story and then we both
will figure out what's the next right
step if you want to be on the show give
me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask
a-s-k all right let's go out to Boise
and talk to the great Stephen what's up
Steven in Boise
hey how's it going John thanks for
taking my call you got it man we're
partying how about you
oh you know just just living the dream
that's so great like the last three or
four shows the first caller always says
I'm living the dream and that almost
always means for sure not living any
sort of dream at all right maybe a
nightmare but what's up man
so my question today is I kind of feel
like I'm realizing I tend towards
codependency and kind of people pleasing
in my life and I've kind of track that's
kind of seeing how my dad example that
for me he's pretty much been kind of on
a codependent type of marriage really
just kind of appeases his way through
through his marriage kind of not
standing up for you know what he thinks
and stuff just trying to not rock the
boat
um just just kind of slide on by and
then you know here here I come up
through life
and go into the life of adulthood and
with friendships and work and especially
like my marriage I kind of find myself
really kind of doing the same thing just
kind of not being the real me just kind
of putting on in front of people what I
want them to see and not really you know
communicating well because I'm just
trying to I kind of just appeasing my
way through life I feel hmm and have you
found yourself that how old are you now
I'm 36. okay 36. so perfect so have you
found in the last four or five years
it's usually running somebody turns
30-ish
um and then on through 35
you have found that the very thing you
are working against which is people
leaving you or abandoning you or getting
frustrated by you
are now leaving you and frustrated by
you and kind of moving on with their
lives
a little bit or kind of you know getting
to where it's it's more seemed like
that's kind of on the verge of being
that as well um there have been a couple
like that yeah so what happened that
precipitated this call like something
usually happened and you're like dude I
got I I've got to think of another way
of doing life what happened
well really it kind of came down to in
my marriage my wife is just kind of like
hey you know man you gotta you gotta
start you gotta stop being frozen in
place and you know you gotta start you
just gotta start you know you know
having to have a direction and not just
worrying about you know what others
think or even even more so I guess you
know maybe on her part as well and again
I'm thinking okay if I go and and say
hey this is this is what I'm thinking
this is what I want to do well maybe it
doesn't really align with hers I know
he's had a couple disagreements on a
thing where we've we've she has an
opinion one way I have an opinion the
other way and in the end I just kind of
go and after a while like I don't want
the fight I don't I don't want to keep
going around around this so sure fine
we'll just kind of do do what you want
to do and then she can see well hey he's
not really
on board with this and so we just kind
of get stuck kind of in that cycle and
that Loop going around and around kind
of the same thing and nothing really
gets resolved because I don't want the
fight and she wants it resolved and I I
don't I don't want to upset her because
I want to go this way and it just yeah I
can't go around around circles
so
just imagine
what happens if you dug your heels in
I don't I'm talking about something
minor I don't want to eat at that
restaurant
I've been thinking about it all day I
don't want to eat there it's gross I
won't eat here
and she gets so mad she says well fine
I'm going by myself and she leaves you
at home that night and you are pissed
and she is so mad
She Gonna Leave You She's gonna divorce
you over that
no not over that would you divorce her
no so what's the thing you're so worried
about
I guess you know that it's that
that I I just want to be
I guess
I don't I don't like to be in Conflict I
just don't like the feeling of the
conflict I guess so I'd rather just say
but you also don't like the life that
you've created which is everybody like
what you think and dream about and
really feel deeply
nobody cares because you have squashed
that so hard
right you kind of bound yourself up
like damned if you do damned if you
don't right
right yeah yeah
oh man was your mom abusive to your dad
um very I say emotionally pretty
emotionally
um there was there was even a couple
times she even threw out the um the
threat of a suicide to get him to do
what she wanted him to do okay
um did that roll over to you too
let me say this so sometimes I could say
abusive and people think like hitting
with sticks and like physical abuse
um in in the psychological world we talk
about position powers and there's the
one up position which is usually not
always but usually men they Flex they
stay they Lord over right they're big
and they lean over they hit they throw
and there's often it's often a feminine
position not again not always but it's
the one down position which is the well
I I guess I just won't eat then y'all
just go do your thing and I won't eat
and or the um well if you weren't so
stupid then I guess this wouldn't have
happened so I guess I'll just I'll just
do it all
um and either one of those is a absolute
power play right and to get what you
want
um and both of them I think are
Insidious in their own ways but which
one did your mom use
uh she can't she used the um I found it
kind of the the second one okay and and
she would also and she would kind of
utilize
um you know silent treatments very well
I mean as as I kind of learned she would
have they would have some issue and she
would just you know transform into this
look like she was you know 40 years
older than she was just moping around
for three days and then suddenly
suddenly you know four days later uh the
sun comes up bright and shiny and she's
all and everything's fine and cool you
think until the next thing comes along
as a kid uh yeah yeah she did that to me
and I I kind of first became aware of
that kind of as a teenager there was one
instance where I kind of had had dropped
the ball on something and instead of you
know her saying hey you know you dropped
the ball in the sun she's like hey you
you upset me you ruined my day and kind
of you know put it back upon herself and
and then you know went to the kind of
the same emotions
so I'll catch some Flack for this and I
don't care
I think parents who utilize the silent
treatment on their children that's
abusive
what it's doing is it's taking it's
severing the relationship between the
parent and a child
enforcing the child to rebuild that
connection and that is not a skill or a
task a child can do outside of just any
sort of pleasing Behavior
right there's no way a child can fix
that
can um be restorative because the power
Dynamic is so wonky so anytime a parent
utilizes the silent treatment especially
on the back of what you got which is you
failed me
so I feel this way and it's your fault
12 year old 14 year old 16 year old
nine-year-old and so I'm cutting off my
relationship your relationship with your
mother now just imagine like a football
coach doing that or a soccer coach
hey uh you made me mad so I am cutting
off the relationship with your mom for
three days
that person would go to jail I can't do
that
but inside houses it happens all the
time and so we're really I mean you and
I could talk for a couple hours and so
we're really condensing your life into
just a few minutes but extrapolate that
out here it doesn't surprise me that at
36.
the greatest gift you feel in your body
is everything above the water is still
because
any sort of this any sort of
dysregulation any sort of um trying to
think of it any sort of fires in the
house
got you cut off from Mom you watched
your weak father just get beat down and
you guys were left trying to control Ma
how mom felt and that's no kid's job
okay and now you got a wife
that is somewhat begging you will you
please tell me what you want
I don't want to be married to uh I can't
anchor into a sponge that will just is
just gushing through life and we'll do
whatever their boss says whatever their
stupid friend says whatever dumb
neighbor says whatever little college
roommate says I want somebody who I can
anchor into and
who can anchor into me we can do this
thing together
so she's asking you for that why are you
scared to put that out there
yeah I guess like I said before is it's
I I have those feelings of okay I just
don't want
people upset at me or I just don't want
the conflict that I would just I would
just rather I'd rather just hide under a
rock than deal with the conflict and
then
um and then you know again kind of I
guess those those same feelings of being
a kid kind of again where you know I was
pretty much trained hey just just just
just just make Mom happy just just kind
of say what she wants even if you don't
even if you don't feel that's what you
really want just do that and your life
will will go you know you'll be able to
slide on by there you go and what I
don't want for your marriage is either
of you to slide on by
I want you all to tangle and co-create
something magic and good for you you
married somebody that's not your Mom it
sounds like
sounds like you married somebody that
really wants you involved in this thing
right how long you've been married
uh 14 years how many kids you got
five God Almighty five kids okay so is
she watching this thing recreate itself
yeah or she feels like she's got to make
every decision for every person all the
time
yeah I feel like I'm kind of a
minute here
and does she feel like she is
um has a sixth kid in you
I think so yeah she's she's sometimes I
I know if she's really kind of said that
out loud but this kind of in some of the
some of the actions and things said I
could kind of sense that
do you also feel this this fear of
conflict with your kids too
I guess yeah probably a little bit
um
uh where we haven't had like any like
major stuff yet the oldest is 12 but so
she's getting to the point where we're
probably going to be hitting more you
know she comes into her um more more
conflict and stuff and that I guess that
kind of scares me a little bit all right
so
the idea of codependency
is I value other people's lives more
than my own
okay
if we drilled and I'm gonna let them do
whatever they want whenever they want
however they want
because at the end of the day I can't
imagine my life without that
relationship my life ends my oxygen runs
out without this relationship so I'll
let him drink I'll let him abuse me I'll
let them do whatever they want
I don't necessarily hear that with you
okay what I hear with you is somebody
who is very conflict avoidant
and in a weird way you may not even
really care kind of like what my wife
was asking me about my wedding like
it took us a minute like for her to
understand like no I'm for real I just
want to marry you I I mean I don't I
literally don't have an opinion on where
we eat what we don't do I want this kind
of music and she's like cool do that so
sometimes there's some negotiation there
here's what you've got to do moving
forward number one you've got to decide
I'm breaking the cycle that I grew up
with
and that means you have to acknowledge I
don't have a set of skills that I'm
gonna have to get and then I'm gonna
have to practice those skills you are
Shaquille O'Neal back in the day
I can't make a free throw that means
I've got to practice free throws I can
dunk the basketball nobody can stop me
in the paint but I can't make a free
throw I've got to practice free throws
that's what you're gonna have to do and
what that means is you're gonna have to
practice saying out loud I want this I
need this
we're going to go eat here
's my boundaries on X and Y and Z
whatever
and then you're gonna have to practice
feeling super uncomfortable
and letting that feeling just roll
through you and probably come up with
some sort of language with your wife and
say honey you're about to
um
get a whole new husband but it's going
to take me some I'm gonna have to I'm
gonna have to work to get there will you
help me
and she'll say oh my God that'd be
amazing and say I know you probably
don't think it's super hot to hook up
with your another sixth son so I'm gonna
become your husband
um what do you need
and let her tell you here's what I need
and then you have the courage and the
strength to say here's what I need
and then y'all can start working on
meeting each other's needs and you're
gonna what you're gonna find is the
whole thing lifts up it's just gonna
take some time because you are literally
taken 35 years of life and trying to
control all delete it in in in many in
many ways
and also by the way you don't have to
lose your compassion and you're kind of
just chill attitude towards life
that can still be a part of who you are
you're not just going to turn into like
Jocko and be like all right let's go run
50 miles that's probably not gonna
happen
but you can have some opinions and you
can't put your foot down and your wife
can put her foot down and that's when
the real fun begins but if you both put
your foot down in service of this
incredible marriage that we get to
decide what it looks like in this life
we're building for our five kids
um then those those disagreements are
absolutely worth it
it's got to navigate how it looks for me
I'll tell you for me and my wife
um we don't do good with spur with
um uh it's not spur of the moment but
with flash fights the thing comes up and
I say this and she says that we both
know we're gonna put a pin in this and
talk about it later because we're not
going to solve it right then because her
her things kick in my things kick in and
all of a sudden it's we're not we're
fighting we are not trying to solve the
problem but then we loop back in a day
at the end of that day and 30 minutes
later depending on what we're talking
about and or a week later man we can
solve that thing no problem and I like
hearing what she has to say about it and
I like feeling uncomfortable and be like
ah I really thought this but I think but
dude I love that stuff and like you
um let's take some practice
take some practice I think your head in
the right way I think that let's do this
let's start this exercise with this I
want you to sit down today by yourself
and write down in your marriage here's
four or five things I really really need
here's four or five things I really want
for me and my wife I want for me I want
for my kids
and then I want you to take your wife
out and read those out loud and tell her
this is making me nervous and
uncomfortable but I'm committed to
changing this I want to give you
something concrete to Anchor into
then we're gonna practice getting there
and hear hers too she's got a she's got
a role to play here and the role's Not
Your Mama
her role is your wife your partner your
co-creator
person that's building this life with
you you got it brother thank you for uh
being brave and give me a shout be right
back
[Music]
hey what's up deloney here it's that
time of year where a lot of us are
traveling again I mean I've been
traveling flying driving living out of
hotels and that's all fun and good for a
while except when you're camping whoa
but it can all get so exhausting and you
know this as well as I do can wreck your
sleep that's why there's nothing like
coming home to your own bed especially
when you've got a world-class mattress
like a dream Cloud dream Cloud
mattresses will make an incredible
difference in the quality and depth of
your sleep which is an absolute Game
Changer especially when you're traveling
all over creation right now dream cloud
is offering their biggest deal ever
exclusively for our listeners 40 off of
all mattresses plus an additional fifty
dollars in savings listen if you're not
excited to come home to your own bed
it's time to make a change visit
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
John deloney to get your new mattress
today that's dreamcloudsleep.com
and enter promo code John deloney
all right we're back let's go out to San
Antonio and talk to Kristen hey Kristen
what's up
hey Dr John how are you fantastic how
are you
good thanks for taking my calls your
course a celebrity in our home and there
may be a little jealousy Brewing that
I'm getting
good thank you well I am assuredly not a
celebrity in my own home so I'm glad I'm
famous in somebody's house that makes me
feel better thank you hey so what's up
well I've got there's a lot to this so
I'm just gonna jump right into it
Cannonball let's do it
made an appropriate boundary
bound story of course at eight at eight
years old I was the victim of a
murder-suicide and lost both of my
parents
I was subsequently raised by my maternal
aunt and her husband
so fast forward 35 years later I have
been married I have a fantastic husband
he's the greatest in the world and I
have three adult children that are great
also we have our two our two oldest
children are out of the house and we
have a 19 year old daughter who has
special needs she is diagnosed with
autism anxiety and bipolar disorder so
she's our sidekick she goes everywhere
with us she functions at about a 14 year
old level
so we went home this weekend to see
family and stayed at my I stayed at my
parents house and I'm going to refer to
my aunt and uncle as my parents because
that's what I was conditioned to do as a
young child so we stayed at my parents
house
um also my dad's sister and her husband
came into town
uncle is a kisser he always has been
nope nope a kisser and a hug her nope
so it's always been super weird to me
even as a as a young kid I dreaded it
but it was like hey that's him he's
weird what are you gonna do about it
that's assault no
so I don't necessarily think of him as a
pervert doesn't matter doesn't matter
it's weird right it's wrong listen
listen it's not weird
if somebody
touches you puts their mouth on you
and we use the word kissing and it has a
different connotation and sometimes it
can be innocent
if an adult puts their mouth on a child
or on somebody else who doesn't want
their mouth on their body
that is assault
period it's not well he's just weird
it is a violation of bodily autonomy
can't do it that's exactly where I'm
going so we my my 19 year old daughter
expressed after after uncle had kissed
her at lunch Mommy I don't like that and
I'm like oh me either I've been dealing
with it for 35 years it's gross Mom you
go to war mom go to war for your special
needs daughter
that's what happened good so I
tell and it's like I know it's so weird
whatever and and she kind of blew me off
and
you know I just I said she doesn't like
it well you know what happened to the
days when kids were disrespectful of
their elders and they just did what they
did you know God dude you are freaking
me out man that's abuse that's abuse
it's abuse no no no she just told me my
kids could stand to be a little more
respectful that my kids don't spend
enough time with her they don't hug her
and unfortunately my children are overly
close to anybody in our family because
my husband served in the military we
weren't home air quote home for my kids
to be close to any one relative and so
it's just never been a thing that I've
been like oh you've got to go hugging
you've got to go do this I just didn't
do that because I knew my kids weren't
close Christian
you are right
okay
number one hold on listen number one
um on my end and I get to be this way
because I'm not in your shoes I'm
disgusted that your mom talked to you
like that
it made this a matter of integrity and
honor and back in the old days when kids
would just let adults do whatever they
wanted
that like makes me sick to my stomach
because I got a seven-year-old little
girl
and I'll be damned if somebody's gonna
do that to my daughter holy smokes
yeah now hold on hold on hold on
number two
what this Uncle is doing is wrong and
his defense maybe nobody's ever told him
your special needs daughter reached out
to Mom
and in all due respect you put her in a
situation
with somebody who has repeatedly made
you feel uncomfortable your entire life
and violated you your whole life
and she looked at you and said mom
please I don't like this
that's your job right now right and if
she was a 19 year old and she called my
show and she didn't
um was didn't have the cognitive
capacity of a 14 year old and wasn't
struggling with a bunch of cognitive
challenges I would tell her don't ever
go again and if your parents throw a fit
then walk away from your parents because
they're putting you in a crazy situation
she doesn't have that kind of autonomy
she's with she's stuck with you guys so
it's your job to say no
and you can on her behalf tell your uh
your uncle
she doesn't like to be hugged or kissed
so please don't do that
okay and then if you violates that he
through his behavior is choosing for you
all to not come around
period okay you all aren't leaving y'all
aren't abandoning the family y'all
aren't after all we did for you no
pervert Uncle over here
is chosen for us to leave because he
can't keep his mouth off my 19 year old
daughter's body
right period
and I would go to Dairy Queen with my
family there in Texas or actually I
wouldn't go to Dairy Queen I would go to
some awesome Mexican restaurant because
you'll have the best food on the planet
in San Antonio
I would eat myself into a diabetic coma
and I'd with a smile on my face because
I'm not gonna be around that crap I'd
smile on the way home
so bodily autonomy when my husband
dropped that word on her very
respectfully also good for your husband
not a boy look at look at Texans coming
around it's awesome yeah well he was
like Dr John would tell me to say that
so it was like a complete shift in her
demeanor and she asked us to leave good
she she was that upset and told us that
she told me that I let an 85 year old
man ruin our relationship she didn't
tell us to have a safe trip home nothing
she decided she decided that an 85 year
old man had more of a right to y'all's
body than y'all do
that's what she decided and by the way
she's the adult she's the parent now I
know you're an adult and there's a
mutual respect and all that kind of
thing
she's your mom
and if she's gonna let an 85 year old
man who can't keep his mouth off people
come between y'all and she's immature
and it breaks my heart for you because
you don't need to lose another mom but
she walked away
and that's my that's my other thing is
that I for 35 years have have long to
have this mother figure I know the
accepting of me and what and and so it
has nothing to do with you I know I've
just done everything to try to appease
her and make her happy
ever does
because I guess that's where I'm at it's
not about you I hate this I hate it I
hate it I hate it
because it just severtise
you didn't she didn't and the way she
spoke to my husband she severed the
boundaries not you
okay
yeah
what you have to do is deal with the
heartache and the grief that your mom
did that
not yeah
somebody I feel like you know I feel
like I'm walking on eggshells with my
sisters now and I feel like you know I
think because she's made me feel that
way but in reality what I want to do is
protect my kids at all costs and protect
you protect your own dignity you've put
up with the stuff your whole life
I have it's time it's time for you to
stop Reaching For This Woman's approval
it's you're never gonna get it
she'll continue why isn't that so hard
for me to grasp I because again 35 years
I've I've sought her approval and I've
never once gotten it no because because
you're
because you're still a little girl
wondering why your mom left
you're still a little girl wondering
this woman came in and said I'll let you
and I'll take I'll take over from here
and what a gracious beautiful gift your
your aunt who you call Mom gave you
and then she there were lots of strings
attached she weaponized that that's
right she weaponized it so it's both and
she gave you a roof and she gave you
food and that came with a lot of strings
I did and now you're an adult and you
see it and sometimes when you're an
adult with integrity and you're an adult
who
um
uh has learned from the dumb things
you've done in your childhood and you
look back
it's disgusting
to see other adults who haven't yes
right it's maddening right it almost
makes you feel insane like am I the
crazy one but here's here's how I found
in my life how I cut through some of
what you're dealing with with your
sisters
and it is to stop using what I call the
soft Landing words
like
just tight hugs or ugh kisses that's a
soft way of saying he keeps putting his
hands all over my body
he keeps putting his mouth on my
daughter's body
and when you use very descriptive
language of what's Happening
he keeps rubbing his forearm on my
breast and I don't like it huh he keeps
whatever the he keeps putting his hands
really low on my back to where his
fingers touch the top of my butt and I
hate it right whatever the language is
be very specific and everybody gets it
you can't deny it at that point and they
can call you dramatic
oh my gosh it's not putting your mouth
it's just kissing and it's just gross
whatever it's just fun it's just Uncle
Dan cool y'all knock your lights out put
your daughters in that situation
moms of the year
I just don't want to teach my daughter
that to start you know suffer through
this
worse than
you know I don't I don't know the
greatest gift a mom can give her
daughter a is to believe her and B is to
say I hear you and I'm taking you out of
Harm's Way
okay
and so at this point
am I burning a bridge do I sever ties I
I don't feel like I owe anyone an
apology I feel super guilty listen
you've heard this show enough choose
guilt over resentment every time yes I
know my husband already told me you were
going to say that you're gonna feel
guilty you're gonna feel guilty you're
gonna feel guilty it's better than
hating your mom
yeah so choose guilt
guilt that you feel bad that all those
things that's normal that's fine my
daughter just kept telling me I'm so
sorry Mom if I hadn't said anything we
wouldn't be doing this I said absolutely
not this is not your fault this is
bigger than you I want you to do
something to this evening
um and if she can hear it and again
she's got a lot going on so this is easy
for me to say on this side of it and
actually I'm saying this for not only
for you but for every mom with a
daughter in a similar situation and by
the way this is a super common situation
and most of the time the men involved I
don't think are bad guys
right I don't think they're all perverts
and they're all just trying to get some
from young girl I don't think so I think
they're trying to forge connections
and the only way they know how is
through hugs and kisses
yeah okay that's just I think that's the
that's the Playbook and they didn't have
a language for assault they didn't have
a language
intimate and I reserve that for my
husband there you go well I would hope
so I would hope it's not for your uncle
right no God no but listen here's what I
want you to do with your daughter so
weird I want you to
sit down with your daughter so that
y'all are eye level
even if she sits down and you get on
both knees in front of her
and I want you to put both hands on both
sides of her face
and I want you to tell her I am so proud
of you
my heart's about to burst
because when I was a little girl
Uncle so and so did that to me all the
time and I hated it and I hated it and I
hated it
and either I never said anything
because I wasn't allowed or I said
something a lot and my mommy didn't
protect me
I'm gonna protect you
I know I want you to make her feel not
just through words but I want her to
experience you saying I'm so proud of
you
okay I can do that I'll do it
I'm proud of her I know I want her to
have a voice you've taught her you've
taught her that you've taught her that
for 19 years
yes and what this also means
let's just cut to like be super clear
this also means you and your husband and
your other kids y'all probably have to
have a different Thanksgiving Christmas
this year
that's okay that's okay plan it be
intentional about it we're all going to
North Carolina for whatever we're all
going to Dallas and we're don't go to
Dallas we're all going to Houston for
whatever like whatever but okay we're
going we're doing our own thing this
year
okay and at some point maybe maybe Mom
can have a rational conversation
and she'll say what happened what did we
do to make you and you can say with all
love in your heart and respect and
kindness
Uncle so and so made me feel
uncomfortable and he kissed me and he
touched me whatever
for 40 years
then he did it to my daughter
come to find out he did it to one of my
other daughters too
and as long as he comes to these things
me and my family as for our house we're
opting out and so at the end of the day
Mom you get to choose and that's okay
and I know you've got a lot going on
but Mom you get to pick
and then you just smile because she's a
grown-up it's about time she stopped one
down positioning everybody and pulling
the whole boat around underneath the
water
right I mean we very much were raised to
hide your crazy and just go on just you
know we were supposed to be very stoic
and not tell anybody anything those days
are over good for you Kristen good for
you
[Music]
I'll hide my crazy that's fun
it comes to people abusing my daughter
violating her part of the autonomy
nope
nope by the way that goes for my son too
that goes for my wife too that goes for
me too
those days where we all just be quiet
and let Uncle so and so be weird all
Uncle so and so that's over and let it
be over in your house too
and she'll call Kristen you are awesome
we'll be right back
this show is sponsored by better help
hey folks all of us need a little
guidance sometimes in life we're faced
with tough situations and choices and
the way forward isn't always clear I've
been in that position in fact I'm in
that position right now and therapy is
helping me find a path through it
whether it's a career decision
relationship at a Crossroads or some
other struggle you're facing you need
someone to talk with to move ahead with
confidence so if you've ever considered
therapy I recommend better help better
help connect you with a licensed
therapist who can walk with you on that
journey to discover who you want to
become betterhelp is entirely online so
it's convenient flexible and it fits
your schedule whatever your schedule may
be just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge so let
therapy be your map with better help
visit betterhelp.com deloney today to
get 10 off your first month that's a
better help hel
p.com slash deloni
all right Rebecca let's go out to
Chattanooga and talk to Amanda what's up
Amanda
Hi how are you hi I'm doing great how
about you
I am okay
okay I will I will revise my answer and
say I'm okay too what's up
um so I'm calling because uh my husband
had a dysfunctional whatever you want to
say a relationship with alcohol
um
and it just kept spiraling out of
control and led to the point where it
caused
a giant issue with me and our kids and
it started affecting our kids so giant
issue like abuse or screaming and
yelling okay like screaming yelling
verbal
um
questions of physical but nothing I ever
saw
um but I mean what do you mean questions
like a kid saying he hit them
um
in the head so
um and that was an issue and that led to
me removing
myself and the children from the
situation
um for a period of time until there were
signs of improvement
um and that Improvement came
um of stopping drinking and there was
anger and then remorse came and then
once we kind of reunified as a family
the remorse went away and the anger just
stayed
um and so I don't know how to move
forward in this we're in marriage
counseling
um
and a lot of it's just
there wants to be blame placed on
everyone but himself
and he'll own that the drinking was a
problem but he won't own
the anger and the I mean the things that
come along with things like that where
you just your marriage is going to start
falling apart when something like that
is in the house so can I be can I be
real honest with you
yes
unfortunately
throughout my career I've had the honor
and
like heartbreaking responsibility of
sitting with women in a very abusive
relationships
and there's a very
um similar
evasive way they communicate
and I'm hearing that language with you
because if you were to actually lay out
in systematic order here's what happens
here's what me and my kids experience
you would be faced with I know what I
have to do
yeah
is that fair
probably yes I want to honor your
evasive language I'm not going to press
you on it yeah
I'm gonna throw a couple things out that
you can either say yay or no or you can
just not even answer okay yeah
you can
come home
or let me put this way when that car or
truck drives up
your heart starts beating faster
and either your kids start getting a
little bit maniacal or they go hide
and you don't feel safe in your own
house or you're always looking to see
where every kid is and what's their
relationship with Dad
it's true so isn't
he's a great father and he loves the
kids drunk and hit one of your kids in
the head
yes okay
um
I want you to revise what you just said
because good fathers who love their kids
don't get hammered and hit their kids in
the head
yeah
and I'm a father so I'm just going to
stand by that statement yeah no that's
true
um
and if they do
they are on their face in the mud and
gravel
yeah saying they're sorry and they will
go to hell and back to get well and heal
themselves so that crap never happens
again
yeah and that's that's where I'm at is
that's not
um
there's just a blame there's no
ownership there's some ownership and
then it's like well this happened and
you did this and you do this to me and
our life is like this because you do
this and it's just okay let me ask you I
mean is some of that what are you saying
true or no is it all nonsense
um some is true yeah like the the like
um like we have communication problems
in our marriage and I asked him to stop
drinking several times and he wouldn't
and when he went stop drinking I just
distanced myself from him um because
every time I would hang out with him it
would
uh turn into either a fight or he would
make a snarky comment at me and it was
just what is what specifically is he
saying that you do
I control our lives and I give him no
control
and then I asked him and he says that I
need to make changes and I ask him what
changes and then I am not given any
response
um
it's just y'all are in marriage
counseling right now go yes okay
so here's what I think the the next step
is because everything feels very
amorphous
and what he needs is a cold dose a a
cold splash of water of reality
and that means you have to do the work
of being very specific crystal clear
this stuff changes
or me and kids leave
period
and it was you did that once and you
said the drinking has to stop and it did
what you didn't you what you thought was
with the drinking stops then all this
other crap will stop too
and what you found out the hard way is
drinking was just covering up all this
other stuff and deeper issues
and so now we have to deal with the
safety issues and we have to deal with
the blame issues we have to deal with
the whatever issues
but if you're going to one of those
therapists that's just like and how do
you feel and how does that make you feel
and how does that make you feel you're
just talking in circles man
yeah and that's not the case but anytime
she brings something up
he gets really defensive and angry
um like and if the focus is on him right
now because of what's happened
um and he's just like I'm tired of just
talking about me
um
so I don't know here's the deal you
can't control what he does you can't
control what he thinks you can't control
any of that all you can control is you
and I would be very very specific
and then also if you and your therapist
and him have worked out you're right
Amanda you do do these things
then the onus is on you if you're safe
now now for instance
you don't ever want to have sex with me
that's bullcrap well if you come home
drunk all the time or if you're angry
all the time or if the kids are yelling
and you're on the couch with a beer or
you're on the couch with your feet
propped up going hey are we going to
hook up tonight then no we're not having
sex right so that it's within a context
but if there is he walks in the door and
you heard the little your kids away like
little ducklings and then he says well
you disappear every time that's probably
true
and so I'll address those my behavior my
participation in this where I can where
I can keep us safe I will
but I'm going to be very specific about
what I need in my home
and if he says I'm not doing that then
he has made a choice to not participate
in that home because you made a choice
that for his participation to continue
this is the way this has to be
yeah and y'all it sounds like there's
some very
um
it just sounds like somebody at some
point needs to cut through all the well
yeah but you make yeah and everybody's
just got to get through the clarity
because you're doing it to him too right
like I don't know I just like you're
angry what does that mean well it just
feels let's just be real clear with each
other how does that sound
even yeah I I but it won't I've tried
because that's a but I guess I need to
try again well it's more you have to try
and with your counselor you have to work
out your or what moment
yeah
and that's the other side of this
and sometimes it's a smart thing when
somebody's really struggling with anger
to have
um a very clear designated 30-day
separation
I we need to separate here so that you
can get a grasp of your anger
and there's some rules about that type
of Separation very clear paths and that
type of Separation
um and it's it's it can be very very
healthy
and revealing but it allows everybody to
be calm because nobody's having good
conversations if he feels attacked and
you feel attacked and that makes him
angry and that makes you shut down
whatever no no one's no one's getting
anything from that but if there's a
agreed upon contract between the two of
you with your therapist we're gonna take
30 days and and separate here he moves
out you all move out what I don't care
but we're gonna figure it out that's a
common thing with somebody struggling
with anger that just can't get the rates
under control or somebody who's
experienced anger and just their nervous
system won't let them be safe in their
own house first for a second
yeah makes sense and maybe that's the
path you just have to sit with your
counselor and come up with your or what
statement you do these things or
yeah it's
it's not like an ultimatum or no or kind
of yeah that's exactly what that is yeah
okay yeah
yeah he keeps saying what are you gonna
do if I drink again
that's a great question
yeah what are you gonna do
I don't know you do like every time my
every time that I think about it my
like because I it involves leaving I
think
um that's what I say I think you know
yeah
thank you absolutely no and I also think
that he knows you shut down yeah
the same as you know how to spin him up
yeah that's true
and you never ever do that do you
no of course he needs to have his or
what moments with you
I can't live in a home where somebody's
controlling and and demands this and
this and this and this and this from me
okay he gets to do that and you need to
have your
here's what I need for me and my kids to
feel safe
and if he got drunk and hit your kids in
the head once I promise you it's
happened before and as your mom I mean
as the mom you got to believe your kids
until proven otherwise okay
cool
yes can I just tell you this I hate this
for for you I hate this for your husband
hate this for your kids hate this for
everybody
thank you I hate it for you me too
the words moving forward are Clarity
Clarity Clarity and then a little more
clarity
what do you need what do you want and in
partnership with your counselor with the
marriage counselor
here's my line of demarcation here is
here is my or what statement
and I do think it's fair for him to get
his or what statement to but it's time
for both of y'all to start being very
clear
I hate it for y'all hate it hate it hate
it
a hope and prayer for you guys is y'all
are able to
find peace in your home
your husband's able to find peace and
put the needs of his family and your
kids and this thing y'all are have built
that thing y'all built is wobbly and
it's fallen over
but he commits you commit to build
something telling you I hope that's my
hope that's my hope it's gonna be hard
That's My Hope we'll be right back
[Music]
it seems so
so but most of us way undervalue real
genuine relationships our friendships
our marriages we don't know what we're
doing and instead of diving into the
mess we accept shallowness and
distraction and we wallpaper over our
loneliness so let me say this boldly you
cannot be well alone you've got to get
connected to real life people and have
deep powerful relationships I'm talking
about relationships where you can be
honest where you can open up where you
can share hard things and you each know
that you'll still show up for each other
and in my new book own your past change
your future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right we are back hey and in a break
from tradition um we're gonna go with
one of Ben Hill's favorite
um artists in the world
um across his chest he actually has
Miranda Lambert's face in a like it's a
strange tattoo I'm not gonna lie but um
almost prisony looking but it's cool
um and uh man when he heard that second
caller say
uh mama says hide the crazy he's like oh
that's one of my favorite songs songs
called Mama's Broken Heart Ben this
one's for you and for caller number two
Miranda writes I cut my bangs with some
rusty kitchen scissors I screamed his
name to the neighbors called the cops
and I'd numb the pain at the expense of
my liver don't know what I did next all
I know I couldn't stop word got around
to the bar flies and the Baptist my
mama's phone started ringing off the
hook I can hear her saying she ain't
gonna have it don't matter how you feel
it only matters how you look
go and fix up your makeup girl it's just
a breakup run and hide your crazy and
start acting like a lady because I
raised you better gotta keep it together
God this song's making me angry even
when you fall apart
this ain't my Mama's Broken Heart good
for you Miranda
parents
stop telling your kids to quit feeling
because that's how this thing just keeps
rolling through generation to generation
to generation love you guys bye
foreign